-My next guest
is a talented actor,
who stars
in "The Suicide Squad,"
which is in theaters
and streaming now on HBO Max.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Jai Courtney!
-♪ Jai Courtney
makes the crowd applaud ♪
♪ For his new movie,
"The Suicide Squad" ♪
♪ You know he rides with
the DC Comics gang ♪
♪ So give it up
Captain Boomerang ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Grab a seat, buddy.
Looking good!
Jai, welcome.
Welcome to the show!
-Thank you, very much.
-You're looking very sharp.
-Thank you.
-Also, I like the 'stache.
Is that new?
-You like that?
-I love it, in fact.
-Yeah.
-Is it for a role?
-It's not necessarily.
-Okay.
-I think I'm gonna
hang on to it for the one
I'm about to do, but...
-Oh, really?
-I kind of --
This came to me
during, like, deep pandemic.
You know,
when I think everyone was --
had a mullet at some point...
-Yes.
-...and a big mustache.
-Yeah.
-And I don't know.
I just feel like I found
my vibe, like, you know?
-Yeah, I think it works.
-I arrived finally.
-I think it works for you, yeah.
I love it.
You guys love it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a bit of a slug,
as they call it, you know?
They call it a slug.
-It's a good --
But it's a good 'stache.
-It's a good slug.
-Mine's a bit wispy
when I grow mine out.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah?
-And it's a little sad.
And -- just panned.
Universally panned, my mustache.
I grew one, and I go,
"What do you think?"
and everyone just said, "No."
-No one likes it. No.
-They didn't even say like --
"Give it a break or --"
-Some people
just can't pull it off.
-No.
-My dad had one in like
the '80s and '90s,
and I feel like
I just look like him now, but...
-Yeah, my dad
always had a mustache.
Still has one.
And I remember one year
he shaved it,
and that was traumatic day.
-It's a weird thing
when someone shaves it.
-It's bizarre.
Me and my sister were like,
"Who are you?"
Like, "Why are you
in our house?"
[ Laughter ]
He just looked like
a totally different person.
-Seen parts of their face
you never seen before.
-No, exactly.
He grew it right back.
I was like, "You can just put
a fake one on. I don't care."
-Sure.
-Go back to old dad.
Now, you are --
You are from Australia,
and now you came over here
in L.A.
You're working on something
in New York.
Did you know any other
Australians working in L.A.
when you moved to Los Angeles?
-When I moved, I didn't, no.
Know quite a few now, obviously.
But when I first got out,
didn't know anyone, really.
I -- I got to know someone
who's now a friend.
Russell Crowe you might know.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good mate of mine.
-He's the greatest.
-He'd probably kill me
for telling this story.
But when we first met
at a big, silly Hollywood party,
and I was very, like,
kind of intimidated,
because it's Russell, you know?
He kind of
has that air about him.
But I -- you know,
I was a huge fan.
So I thought I would say
g'day to him.
And I was like,
leaned over and said,
"Hey. Sorry, Russell,
I'm just a huge fan, you know?
I'd just
really love to meet you."
And he goes, "What's your name?"
And I said, "Jai,"
and he goes "Courtney."
And I go, "Yeah," and he goes,
"You want to smoke a joint?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"[Bleep] yeah, man."
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-First meeting Russell Crowe,
he's like --
-Day one.
Well, he keeps it real, Russell.
And we got
to work together, actually,
not long after that on a -- on a
film called "The Water Diviner"
that he directed,
which was a lot of fun and --
Big respect for him,
that's for sure.
-Oh, he's the greatest.
I love Russell.
Please tell him
I said, "What's up?"
-He's a friend of the show,
I know,
so I'm sure
he'll appreciate that.
-I heard that you're also --
you're a very good cook,
especially pizza.
-I wouldn't say
I'm a very good cook.
I'm an all right cook.
I make some mean pizza, though.
I do make some mean pizza.
I've got like a --
one of those, like, a wood-fire
oven in the backyard.
So I've been doing a lot of that
while things were sort of down,
particularly last year.
Keeping it quiet, slinging
a bit of pie, as they say.
-Do they say that?
-I say it.
-Yeah, you do, yeah.
But do you --
you have to put logs into this,
because I know --
-Yeah, well, it's a little one.
It's kind of portable.
And so, you feed, like,
a chamber at the back
with, like, smaller logs.
It's not the hard-core like --
-But still, like --
-You can get away with it.
-I got a picture that you --
This is your pizza here.
This is unbelievable.
-Oh, yeah.
That's one of my pies.
-Jai.
-Yeah.
-You crushed.
I mean, I tried to do it, too,
and get a pizza going.
Here's how mine --
-You make pizza?
-Well, I made this.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not bad.
-It's not bad, right?
It looks like --
[ Laughter ]
It looks like this isn't cooked
or something.
-It's a little blonde.
It is a little blonde.
Yeah, that was --
-Do you make your own dough?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't make your own dough?
-No.
Do I make my own dough?
No.
-You buy the dough?
-Well, I go to
the local pizzeria, and I go,
"Can I buy the dough from you?"
-That's fair enough.
You leave it to the
professionals.
-And the sauce.
And the --
-You should tell them
to cook it for you, as well.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's actually a good point.
This looks great, bud.
Next time you come on,
I'd love to get a pie, man.
-Let's do it, for sure.
-We'll sling some pies.
What's on this guy?
-That's, like, my specialty.
I do a little pepperoni.
-Love it.
-Some chilies, and then,
I know this is polarizing,
but I'm a fan of pineapple
on my pizza.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you're not,
I don't want to hear it.
It's fine.
I know people are split
with that [bleep] but...
-I would try it.
No, look, our audience --
-It's good.
-It is good.
-All right, next time,
we're having a taste test.
"Suicide Squad."
Congrats on this.
-Thanks, man.
-This is the second time...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...that you're playing
Captain Boomerang.
-That's right.
-That is a fantastic name.
-Isn't it a great name?
-That's who I would want to play
if I'm in "The Suicide Squad."
I go, "Who's playing
Captain Boomerang?"
-Yeah, Captain Boomerang.
-Yeah, and a lot of people
online have been really
stomping for a spinoff.
They want to know the origin --
-So am I.
I mean, let's do it.
Get on with it.
Let's go.
Give the people what they want.
-Give the people a stand-alone
Captain Boomerang movie.
-Absolutely.
-You would be up for that?
-Listen, I have a saying,
and it's that
a boomerang always comes back.
-Wow.
-So, I think there's
opportunities galore with him.
We can do all of it --
TV series, spinoff,
whatever you want.
Pop up in "The Flash."
-You're down.
-Warner Bros. are out there.
They know what's up.
-They know what's going on.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jai Courtney
in "The Suicide Squad."
Take a look at this.
-[ Coughing ]
-Yo, is this a dog?
-What?
-I-Is this thing a dog?
-A -- A dog?
-Yes.
-What -- What kind of dog
do you think it is, mate?
-I don't know. I'm not familiar
with all the breeds.
-Oh, my God!
Is it a werewolf?
I wanted to meet
a werewolf forever!
-Yo, they strapped me
next to a werewolf?!
Yo, let me out!
I do not do werewolves!
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, hey, he's not a werewolf!
Okay?
He's a weasel. He's harmless.
I mean, he's not harmless.
He's killed 27 children.
But, you know, we got him to --
I think he's agreed to do this.
Whatever the case, just everyone
get into position to drop.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jai Courtney, everybody!
Captain Boomerang!
Check out "The Suicide Squad."
It's in theaters
and streaming on HBO Max.